I want to give the audience a song that
they can perform what's the lyric
a highly anticipated movie Bohemian
Rhapsody shares the story behind Queen
frontman Freddie Mercury and the band's
iconic anthem it debuts this fall but
it's already getting some Oscar buzz
other films expected to have a big
impact at the box office include a star
is born
featuring Bradley Cooper and Lady gaga
and first man which follows Neil
Armstrong's pioneering journey to the
moon and a goes managing editor Erik
Davis is here with a look at the fall
movies Erik good morning I'm really
excited by all of this yes so but let's
start with the music movies but the main
Rhapsody a star is born is this must-see
stuff oh yeah I mean this just speaks to
a trend that we've been seeing the last
couple of years with lala land and the
greatest showmen these movies that
aren't necessarily musicals but they're
very much driven by their music Bohemian
Rhapsody story here is Rami Malek I mean
he is already being predicted as a Best
Actor frontrunner the film will
chronicle the band in the years leading
up to that legendary Live Aid
performance in 1985 Malick has won an
Emmy for TVs mr. robot keys would be his
first acting Oscar voted number two most
anticipated movie in a survey of over a
thousand moviegoers we did at Fandango
and a fun fact about this film Mike
Myers who famously lip-sync Bohemian
Rhapsody in Wayne's World he has a role
in this film as a record executive
executive well he looks just like
Freddie Mercury he does why did they I
started seeing trailers for this I
cannot wait to see it but I started
saying at this summer if not in this
during why do they start promoting this
so soon today they really think this is
going to be yeah I mean they you know I
think some of these big four movies that
they think have high hostage chances
they sort of get out in front of them
and promote them as early as they
possibly can and so this is a film that
Queen fans have wanted to see for a very
long time movie that took a long time to
come to fruition and so I think there's
a lot of people that are very excited a
lot of people gonna be excited if they
like horror films - yeah right yes
I'm Halloween tell us what we can expect
yeah Halloween this is one of I think my
most anticipated movies of the fall
season this one forgets about all of the
other Halloween sequels that we've seen
it is direct sequel to the original
Halloween John Carpenter who directed
that original which I think is the
scariest movie of all time he returns to
compose a new score for this film highly
acclaimed director guy named David
Gordon Green he
Rex he teamed up with Danny McBride the
actor to make this movie I've seen a
sequence in this film a couple of months
ago I was so frightened I was literally
on top of my buddy up next to me and I
don't get that way I see all these
movies I think this has the makings to
be the big breakout horror hit of the
season similar to the way it was last
and you actually enjoy that sensation I
love movies that are frightening not
less gory I'm not a gory guy but if it's
frightening and just giving you chills
and you're on the edge of your seat
there's nothing better than that I think
in a horror movie talk to us about first
man starring Ryan Gosling what is the
controversy about the flag on the moon
well there's a people that's talking
about the kind of sequence on the moon I
want to be vague here because I want to
spoil the end of the movie but the fact
that the planting of the flag
is not in the movie and why that is and
I've spoken to people on the ground I
can tell your ID Film Festival just
watch this film which told me that
there's American flags all over this
movie yeah but what this movie is it
very much told from the point of view of
Neil Armstrong it's a very personal
movie it's about his journey leading up
to that mission to the moon
and so it's told from his point of view
it's about his family what he was going
through and so I think when they get to
that moon when he stakes those steps
their talk they're looking at what
what's going through his mind in those
moments you know a lot of people forget
Neil Armstrong had a daughter who died
just a few years before he took this
mission and so I think this this film
tackles a lot of personal sort of demons
that he was going through who was this
guy he didn't consider himself a hero
was sort of kind of getting the job done
and I think you know his family Claire
Foy places wife she is already being
talked about for an Oscar she's gonna
have a big fall also the new Lisbeth
Salander and girl in a spider's web so I
think that it's important to see this
movie and to see the context of how it's
being framed
Damien Chazelle last time we saw him and
Ryan Gosling who plays Neil Armstrong la
la la lo and 14 Oscar nominee I mean she
sells an incredible director and and I'm
hearing amazing things about this film
I've not seen it but a lot of people who
are criticizing and haven't seen it
either no no people haven't seen this
film all it was it played at the Venice
Film Festival and a Telluride Film
Festival so only a small group of people
have seen this movie and everyone who
has seen this movie have kind of said
you know what see the context of the
film I think that's very emotional that
Mo's moments when he steps on to the
moon
what I have been told are very emotional
moments because you're with him in this
personal journey and it's I think people
are crying they're saying it's riveting
I can't wait to see it and as you said
there are flags throughout the movie
there are flags rough so much to look
forward to thank you so much Eric Davis